logan paul knocking out someone
practicing he was getting ready for a
slap competition yes some get ready
online on its on yon instagram and
twitter so he's doing this cuz he's
gonna go to rush and was going to do
that was the plan right yeah he's like
doing basically a training camp of
slapping [ __ ] yes - get ready to
compete in the Russian slap competitions
which Christ and then we'll just play
this real quick hey who's this guy
stoppin do we know there's no dude I
guess these practicing on Oh catch him
the guy's head didn't really move great
I've seen people get knocked out from
those slots before yeah Logan so what's
this say now this is him not doing that
the competition anymore due to
unforeseen wasn't a place to impress I
have to say that's pretty smart
yes um he post that video with Chris
D'Elia and then Logan on Chris thing
said nah Bryan let's spar and I thought
it was great funny and then the amount
of hate he got for even saying that and
then I was like joking around going
Logan you're way too big and too young
which by the way is 100% I wouldn't spar
that dude nah he's [ __ ] giant and
athletic okay it's too hard he's also
joke exactly a joking no one's been any
heroes no I'm just kidding big ol no
one's being serious I was like take it
easy he's not he's just joking around
lives in that's just what that is there
was a crazy they came at him I was like
that guy's [ __ ] around he can't say
one thing and they were literally to do
but somebody said look at all the things
I never look at this I went over I was
like all of Jesus but he seems like a
nice guy but I would realize it would
definitely not spar with him
you are so 50 dude I'm 52 and he's a
giant kid and I keep you strong and
boxes a lot I don't need to get hit yes
you could dude yes and he's he's hey
he's Twitter yeah I think I think he's
22 with 50 of money he's 22 so he's
figuring his [ __ ]
he gets it he also learned so like this
right he's like this and he goes holy
[ __ ] people get knocked out of [ __ ] up
from this I'm not doing this in my mouth
there's situation where he had like
those mini pigs you know those aren't
natural and real mean to animals when
people get those miniature pigs he
didn't have any idea I connect them with
Whitney Cummings she's like this is why
they're bad you can't you don't want to
put this out there and help people to
get the email Hawks a leap a lot like
the small ones they're called mini pigs
I think huh and so it's like a new [ __ ]
don't highlight this Jim we know what
people let me see it but so they started
to do that and then Whitney was like yo
you don't want to do this because it's
actually cruelty to animals and Logan
Paul Zach I'll [ __ ] got no idea he's
like how can I contribute and make this
na'toth yeah like geez he's 24 yeah yeah
and and I think what he's a dumb guy
smart insane amount of fear humanism
everything's under a microscope when
you're that way and but also he got big
from being outrageous he's outrageous
dude when you're sitting around with
money in the bank you're like you will
come with some knockout fraud they both
crush it right yeah absolutely crushing
whole business like it's not him just
with one camera guy and they upload
videos to YouTube I'm out and it's so
straight production a team high level
team high level people don't worry love
still I'm getting paid crazy he's
entertainer the people around him are
very I mean they work with some of the
biggest stars also he's at you can see
from his body and his a discipline dude
like he did that's he takes care of
himself you know it's a gift